the rot runs deep that's the focus of
tonight's
Angle now she says she's sorry for what
for saying
this anti-semitic rhetoric when it
crosses into conduct that amounts to
bullying harassment
intimidation that is actionable conduct
and we do take action so the answer is
yes that calling for the genocide of
Jews violates Harvard code of conduct
correct again it depends on the context
it does not depend on the context the
answer is yes and this is why you should
resign now I know what you're thinking
how could someone so ignorant be a
president of a university that graduated
Minds such as Teddy Roosevelt TS Elliott
Robert
Oppenheimer yet this is what the left
has done to our higher education and now
Harvard's claudian gay followed upen
president Liz McGill on the ivy league
apology tour in an interview with a
Harvard Crimson well after their
equivocation regarding campus protest
calling for genocide of Jews MIT Harvard
and upen are still facing massive
backlash from alumni some of whom have
pulled their very large donations to the
schools calls for resignations are
coming from both Democrats and
Republicans but the Harvard president
appeared to at least partly blame the
atmosphere at the hearing itself saying
I got caught up in what had become at
the that point an extended combative
exchange about policies and
procedures but her loest line of all is
when she added substantively I failed to
convey what is my
truth insert the chest thump and the
emoji with the eye roll there now what
unfolded on Capitol Hill this week
shouldn't really be seen in isolation
but instead part of a Continuum of what
the diversity equity and inclusion
agenda has done to even our most
prestigious
universities none of those women should
still have their jobs after what they
said and it's hard to believe that any
of them would be in their positions if
they weren't
women proclaimed victimhood regularly
beats out professed Excellence if you're
from a recognized minority group with a
decent but unimpressive record you too
can become president of Harvard now
consider Miz Gay's own background before
being selected a president of Harvard
she put just published 11 peer reviewed
articles and she had not written a
single book her published works are
steeped in victimology the kind that's
rewarded on campus her Focus was on
black grievance and gender grievance
including the impact of gender and race
on the politics of black women as the
Boston Globe noted other college
presidents have written dozens and
dozens and dozens of Articles and even
several books for instance by comparison
former Harvard president Larry Summers
had written more articles in a single
year that was way back in 1986 than Ms
gay had written in her entire career
when she was appointed but of course
since Summers was a real academic and
perceived as too demanding and blunt by
the snowflakes at Harvard his tenure as
president was cut
short diversity was the major factor in
Ms Gay's hiring a fact that even her own
colleagues implicitly admitted they
raved about how she had hired ethnic
studies professors as a dean and her
support for the creation of an
undergraduate concentration in ethnicity
indigeneity and
migration well this is all just part of
the oppression mindset which has come to
dominate on college campus es and
knowing how to play that game is key to
climbing the ladder in Academia and
perhaps right to the president's office
Harvard has accomplished so much in the
last few years from radically advancing
our understanding of natural and
artificial intelligence to our
Collective commitment to issues around
climate and
sustainability and the Bold agenda of
Reckoning and repair inspired by the
groundbreaking report on Harvard and the
legacy of
slavery the tolerance a vile genocide
supporting anti-Semitism on campus it's
simply a symptom of a disease that has
gripped these universities for decades
and one thing we've learned in recent
years is that America look it's full of
Institutions that are not as nearly
powerful as they appear or want to
appear think about this it's not just
Harvard the GOP establishment looked
unbeatable in its own primaries until
Donald Trump took him on Disney vaunted
Disney looked unbeatable in the State of
Florida until Ronda santis took them on
then there was a Washington Post that
used to be strong enough to bring down a
president now its own people are facing
huge layoffs and
buyouts and now the ivys are facing a
similar judgment president gay and the
other Witnesses at that hearing never
believe though that they would face
consequences from anything they said to
congresswoman
stepanic they thought their titles and
their Prestige would protect them they
always do but they were wrong the ivys
became very rich and very powerful
because they had a reputation for rigor
hard work tradition and Excellence well
that reputation Now lies in tatters not
only in Washington but all over the
world if they want to regain it
they need to begin by hiring presidents
on the basis of Merit and not on
grievance and that's the angle hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else